Thursday night football back on Fox they
were the first two games were on NFL
Network which he was doing it for and
what a season it was on Fox last she was
amazing
Joe Buck calling in I assumed from
Lambeau Field how are you Joe hi you
sound you sound like you didn't get the
motto from from Darnell did you Joe you
sound under the weather no I'm good man
Fox Eagles Packers now you now you sound
like the guy on SportsCenter coming up
on SportsCenter
it's like the weirdest tones man the
years ago because they the years ago Joe
because I guess somebody focus-grouped
it they decided the Sunday night sports
centers needed better teases to break
they needed to have questions asked to
keep you teased throughout the
commercial break so they took that
because we all the Sports Center guys we
and ladies we used to write the tease is
going to break and they didn't like the
way we were doing it so they had that
voiceover a guy do it and so the one
time that they couldn't get him to do it
I did them all in that guy's voice good
oh that's not so good about myself Joe
boy all you all you act SportsCenter
guys just have to let the past go no
seriously
let it go it's like forever ago well I
mean you know you and I you're the cat
you're the man you're the man and NFL
Network I get it I you had a good run I
did an older mend and Patra thing I we
we saw it we lived it we were there and
so you don't like strolling down memory
lane Joe you don't it just seems to
happen a lot there's a lot there's a lot
of strolls you know it's interesting Joe
you did your first World Series the same
year I did my first Sports Center nice
right right that's right so I don't walk
around or put up and social Bay Yankees
are champions of baseball mmm hashtag 96
are you on
social media I don't see you very much
out there yes I don't really frequent
that whole neighborhood too often
anymore you know what I'm not the point
I yeah you're gonna be gonna try to be
funny which is even worse than being
funny when people say he's trying to be
funny right then you know you're just
gonna wade into waters that get you in
trouble and it's just not worth the
fallout in an answer for it for the rest
of time do you know who is on social
media is Troy and I know you know why
well what's the what's the upside well
you know because somebody on the
athletic in Kansas City was talking
about how a mahomes already has a ton of
yards and how they're what are we got
here 36% of Troy Aikman's career
touchdowns about 8% of the games I see
why am I in case you missed it
talk to me when he has 33 percent of my
Super Bowl titles alright which is which
is 40 but in this world nobody takes it
away then it becomes toiling against
Patrick Mahone's which is not at all
what of course right about the person
who posted it and it's a different game
they didn't ask Troy Aikman to run
around and throw the ball 40 times a
game 45 times a game 50 times a game had
a great line he had a Hall of Fame best
ever running back and Emmitt Smith and
they they won about winning games and
titles a different way so it's just it's
it's not a comparison so that I think
gets under troy skin because i know he
believes that if they needed him to
throw the ball like you know
theoretically Kansas City needs and once
for good reason Patrick the Holmes to
throw the ball like you guys it's really
easy dad you could have done it but
that's that's not you know so he gets
that criticism a lot and it kicks him
off but again you know why I got it but
but here's the thing you know obviously
I know and pretty much anybody who knows
football knows if if mahomes had a guy
who was going to break Walter Payton's
record behind how he would throw a lot
less
and they would run a lot more all that
said I do love red asteroid on Twitter
I've really I get a big kick out of it
I'm out you know part of me I I do like
it when he when he you know when he
shows that side because he had and he
has a really funny side too and every
once in a while we'll get there on a
broadcast and I like seeing that side of
Troy come out more so as much as I said
why why bothering and you have to answer
for it you know I don't I don't run
screaming into the hallway worrying
about it I he can he can defend himself
or himself so if she felt that way then
good for him well and plus I think Jo
you know we've known each other a long
time I fear I could say I feel like
you're in a mood right now I feel like
you're kind of in a mood good calling in
make sure yeah you know I guess I said
you gotta let the sports don't be don't
be don't no no I am just giving you
trouble you get you give trouble all day
you got to be able to accept some
trouble I I try to accept trouble every
time I open my mouth
do you like the nickname Danny dimes
what do you think now I'm with you like
there's no way there's no way on planet
Earth
Joe when you've got Thursday night
football coming up in a couple weeks
Giants and Patriots and you have
obviously a history of calling that game
with big moments last thing you're gonna
do is call him Danny dimes right like
over over a very frozen over warm place
would you do something like that right
correct yeah I would I would not wait
into the day it's a great call by the
way I love it the great call ya know but
Danny times ruins it despite no matter
no matter if you've met the moment or
not Joe you know what I mean Danny's all
eyes I just wouldn't do it I don't know
that I I don't do that a lot you know
like what's the errand ride
a rock no I'm not doing that either
yeah no the a rod obviously I think
that's that's what he is actually called
but that just doesn't work hey Rob I got
a the D and the G in there has a tough
one but your your professional Joe Buck
here on the Richards Joe are you at
Lambeau Field literally right now or no
no I'm not about to about to get out of
Dodge here and saying well as oh when
both field so we just got off our
conference call with the Eagles and I
jumped off actually the Carson Wentz
Horsemen of a conference call because
these times keep shifting as teams you
know try to work in on the short week
their meetings their practices their
flight and so we've got kind of a that
that's that's the one downside to this
because I want us face to face it's a
lot more over the phone right at least
in the case of these two teams as
opposed to last week see the Eagles a
time we know obviously Erin and the
Packers a ton so we'll get as much info
on the phone as with being in person but
when it's Gardner Minshew and guys like
that it's just a little tougher because
they don't they don't know it so what
did you glean from the Philly phone
called we have DeSean Jackson you think
tomorrow night or Alshon Jeffery what
did you glean from all of us I think
confident that al Sean's going to play
not so much for DeSean Jackson they're
not worried about how much Tyson wins
has been hit to this point Carson at the
call says he feels good despite all that
in a short week going in physically and
and I just sensed from talking to Doug
Peterson and Jim Schwartz they're not
thinking the sky is falling at 1 & 2
even though they have to go on the road
and play the Packers I think they
legitimately believe they're 2 plays
away from being 3 and oh and I'm sure a
lot of teams can say that but that's
kind of the way the first three weeks
have gone for them and I think they'll
go I actually think they'll go in and
play really well it
against a really good defense I can't
tell you how many Packer games I've done
but whether it's been Brett Favre and
Rogers you always go in thinking offense
you go into this one thinking about a
team that's leading takeaways and as
pressure from the outside and racking up
sacks it's just a different feel well
and then the subject about Green Bay on
have you conference called with them yet
or you're gonna believe 40 o'clock we've
got a rod and like that well the whole
business is the I mean the offense Joe I
mean that's that's all we hear about is
the offense and the installation of the
offense and then the freedom that
Rodgers has in the offense and what
percentage of the offense have we seen
work and the percentage of offense that
we need to see work and all of that good
stuff and Rodgers has a flat out said
the offense needs to step it up Joe so I
assume that's going to be part of the
conversation you have with Troy and and
those guys for Thursday night yeah no I
mean he's been one of the most dynamic
players in the game and what do you have
a new head coach and a young guy that
comes in with a new system and they're
putting that in it becomes especially
with a veteran quarterback like Aaron
who's got you know he's as smart as
those at home as well as I do he's a
smarter guy as you'll find and really in
any walk of life not just in
professional sports but he's an
opinionated guy he likes things his way
and now you've got you know it's only
human nature to see who how that whole
tug of war and that relationship
develops in the public eye and so on I'm
excited to talk to Aaron and Matt about
how that's all gone to this point but I
think he's right you know the offense
has looked good for short snippets of
time but he's not used to be in middle
of a pocket quarterback rating he's not
used to be in middle of the pack and
offensive numbers he's not running like
he was before this reticle where he said
I'm trying to make first downs and
touchdown throwing it not running with
it and and so it's a
different-looking packer offense and the
best news for them is their three and Oh
they've kind of written their defense
and that fast start against the Vikings
and then we'll see where where the
offense goes from here but yeah it's
that's why it's an interesting game to
me on Thursday night and and a tough one
to pick you know if you were if you were
inclined to do so mm-hmm if you are
inclined to do so well I just know
Packers fans are hoping to see the
Rodgers in this offense the the Rodgers
that they drafted three years after I
left Sports Center for after a
seven-year study what do you mean it's
not me it's it's about you it's me it's
it's been it's been a long time since I
heard that Joe maybe the last time I
heard that was about three years before
I joined SportsCenter in 1996 for my
seven-year stay and I think I a little
more freedom and again is this is no
reflection
no no I've told you this Joe and I don't
know if it's been a while but I will
never forget sitting there and my Sports
Center cubicle in 1996 a die-hard Yankee
fan and I always dreamed about going to
a World Series and for the Yankees and
and and there it was and I couldn't go
because I was so fortunate to be on
SportsCenter way and you were calling
the game and showing off all the Fox all
the Fox celebrities that were in at the
time Fox television's no no it is we
have so many animated don't have to they
didn't have to give tickets to people no
this was actually back in the day Joe
where you said there's Kim fields who is
starring on a series and Fox at that
time I'm like so 2d really is that yes
well back in the day facts of life I
don't know what she was on on life
living single was she owned at that time
I don't know but I know I was just like
wow so 2d is at this game I wanted to go
to but I can't and I just remember that
you okay you were doing your dream you
was I was which is you know why I was so
excited to be there for seven years from
1996 to 2003 right right
and then the NFL came calling 2003
that's right now to President I remind
you 2019 yeah
you've been at NFL Network and doing
such a great job but it's these wistful
memories of time spent and bristles it
yeah it seemed to dominate your thoughts
know now and say dominate I wouldn't say
dominate I just may pepper into your
thoughts they yeah I mean he's reliving
the the days didn't ya know I know yeah
all I heard you guys do back then was
complain about things know all of us
can't you know just be with one network
our whole career you know what I'm
saying we all we all we on you know do
you have do you have the last time I was
told us yeah go ahead play play that for
play play that means there was there
have it you know giving me the it's not
you it's me rutila
I invented it's not yours there you go
Jim that must I'm you know I'm just
giving you trouble forgot I know that
Joe you and I have I feel like you're
like legitimately no Chris tell tell him
how I how I've been looking this entire
now he's good he's good all right I
can't no they're they're from beg borrow
and deal season two on espn2 that I did
Joe back in 2002 I think well thank you
sir take care of Joe you'd be well
served at it are we hanging up I think
so hang up bad no no no we're not don't
know you know the one thing they always
tell you when you get married don't know
I know Joe please I know when I'm a
happy guy and I'm happy with you and
he's gone to bed mad at Suzie Joe the
first thing you think about when you
wake up the next of course because I am
a sensitive individual and you know that
have you ever gone to bed mad at
Michelle absolutely and you were able to
go through the whole hey that's right
and but at least you're able to soothe
yourself and a nice chat with carson
wentz in advance of tomorrow night's
game Joe correct that's what I always do
is just you know if there's something
going on in my life just seek out Matt
Lafleur and talk about the offense take
care of yourself Joseph positive closure
with Joe Buck everybody positive closure
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app